SPEAKER 1: Honor Code, take one.
[CLACK]
SPEAKER 2: Can you
recite the Honor Code?
ANNIE: No.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: Can you
recite the Honor Code?
ANDREW: A Hillsdale
College Student
is honorable in deed-- frick.
OK.
REAGAN: --is honorable
in word and deed.
LUKE: A Hillsdale
College student
is honorable in word and deed.
Lie?
ANNIE: Michelle will
probably know it.
MICHELLE: A Hillsdale
College student
is honorable in conduct,
honest in word and deed,
dutiful in study and service.
LUKE: And he attends classes.
REAGAN: Freedom,
because liberal arts.
MICHELLE: And respectful
of the rights of others.
REAGAN: Brushing
your teeth, it's
good to brush your
teeth, people.
LUKE: He's not late to meetings.
REAGAN: OK, I need
my next line, please.
MICHELLE: Rising to education?
No.
SPEAKER 2: Can you
recite the Honor Code?
BLAKE: Yes, I can.
A Hillsdale College student
is honorable in conduct,
honest in word and deed,
dutiful in study and service,
and respectful of
the rights of others.
Through education, a student
rises to self-government.
SPEAKER 2: Nice.
BLAKE: Thanks.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah,
that was [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
BLAKE: I have to be able
to do it for my job.
That's how we start
all of our meetings.
We recite the Honor Code.
REAGAN: I was, you know,
a senior class secretary.
I need to have these
things memorized.
ANNIE: It's incredible
how these things-- like,
how the words of the
Honor Code, how I don't
remember the specific phrasing.
But, like, it's
integrated into my life.
LUKE: When I first heard that
Hillsdale had an Honor Code,
it was that Dr. Arnn's
speech that he gave
at the beginning of the year.
And it was a pretty,
like, strange, sort
of interesting
thing that I'm not
really used to having,
like, codes given to me.
I went to a public high
school, so we never
had anything like that.
KAMRYN: I think I was on, like,
a little tour around campus.
And we were down
by the cafeteria,
and they said something
about, oh, yeah.
People just leave their
backpacks, and their Mac books,
and their wallets,
and their phones
everywhere, because we have an
Honor Code, so no one touches
anything.
I had never heard anything
like an Honor Code
ever, especially around
a college campus.
ANDREW: The first time
I heard that Hillsdale
had an Honor Code, my
older brother came here.
When I heard that,
I was like, OK,
he's going to a weird school.
But that's what I expected.
He's a weird guy.
REAGAN: The first time I was
on campus hearing Dr. Arnn
talk about the Honor Code,
and the good, the true,
and the beautiful, and I cried.
I cried during that lecture.
It was a little pathetic.
But it wasn't, like,
as dramatic as I am.
It was just like a
little, a little tear.
ANNIE: The Honor Code
just, like, permeates out
into, like,
everything that we do.
Like, you can see
it in the classroom,
in the way that we
respect our professors,
in the way that we respect
other students, in the way
that we do our homework, in
the way that, like, we want
to help one another,
and we don't cheat,
and we're not cutthroat.
We're not trying to, like, tear
other students down or, like,
manipulate them.
But we, like, we want
to help one another,
and do it, like, in a way
that's honest and truthful.
MICHELLE: Yeah, I think when
you view it as a list of rules,
you miss out on
all the good parts.
When it's a way of
life, you choose things
because you love
them, and because you
see them as actually meaningful
and beneficial to you,
not because you have to.
It gains meaning, and
it becomes personal.
VINS: Coming to college
and being independent,
you are away from your parents.
You have a blank sheet to
develop friends and develop
a reputation.
So taking ownership of
that was very important.
It took me a while to
develop that ownership.
MICHELLE: Another phrase you
hear all the time at Hillsdale
is that college is partnership.
When you are aiming
at such a high ideal
and wanting to be people
of excellence and virtue,
you can't do that alone.
So having a community
of people that hold you
to a standard, that
encourage you, that love you,
that teach you, that's powerful.
LUKE: So I think
the best way to take
ownership of who you're going
to be in your four years here
is to find a community
of your peers
that can hold you accountable.
And that when you have to
make those tough choices,
not only you're holding yourself
accountable to something
that the college
expects you to do,
but you're also holding
yourself accountable to a set
of standards that another
community at this campus
has put forward for
you to live up to.
BLAKE: Some of the
relationships that you're
going to build in the first
three months at college,
you're going to be like, how
did I not know these people
my entire life?
And with that, you have to
recognize the strength that
is found in those
relationships, and you
have to be willing to call
people out on certain things,
and understand that you want
to be the type of friend
to other people that you
would like them to be to you.
MICHELLE: Friendship
really comes to a head
when there's conflict or you
know that your friend would
be hurt if you spoke truth.
I think in those moments,
it's selfish as a friend
to just tell them
what's comfortable,
to preserve your friendship now
and hurt them in the long run.
LUKE: And it shows
real, true bravery
to stand up and help somebody
in their time of need.
And it kind of shows the exact
opposite of that cowardice,
if you're kind of shrinking
away from something
that looks wrong, or, OK,
maybe I should say something.
But, they probably know
what they're doing.
But no, if you see
something wrong,
step up, and say something,
and stand up for yourself,
and stand up for
others that need it.
ANDREW: There's certainly a lot
of shenaniganery that goes on.
But we do hold each
other to be honorable.
It is so integral to the very
fabric of what Hillsdale is.
REAGAN: We have a lot of
responsibilities here.
And sometimes, we subject
ourselves to this,
we're still children because
we're still in college idea,
or it's our only chance to act
like kids, which means reckless
and making mistakes
that you're going
to act like you don't regret
for the rest of your life.
And honor matters because
when you are honorable,
you are unified.
You don't have a dissonance
between what you want to be
and what you are.
And it's the little pieces
every day that you choose.
It's decisions, decisions,
decisions, and they shape you,
and they form you, and that
is what makes you honorable,
and all of the things that are
outlined in our Honor Code.
LUKE: I think the person I
want to be when I leave here
is somebody that I looked
up to when I was a freshman.
They exhibited traits of a man
to me when I was a young man.
They showed what it meant
to approach work dutifully.
to stick by your word.
And seeing those
things exemplified
in somebody older than me, I
wanted to emulate those people
when I was younger.
And I think that's just an
amazing thing that we get here.
ANNIE: I think it's all about
trust, the faculty and staff
trusting the students,
and the students
trusting the faculty and staff.
And when those two things
come together, then, like,
you can't see it until
you just, like, trust,
and you have faith, and then
something really beautiful
comes of that.
ANDREW: Character is
important because it is life,
because it's how you
interact with the world,
because it's who you are.
So making sure you
have good character
is something that's incredibly
important, because it is--
I mean, yeah it is you.
MICHELLE: A Hillsdale
College student
is honorable in conduct,
honest in word and deed,
dutiful in study and
service, and respectful
of the rights of others,
rising to education--
no?
Yes, through education
rising to self-government.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
MICHELLE: Did I get it?
SPEAKER 2: Boom.
MICHELLE: Boom.
Oh, man I memorized
it last night.
[LAUGHTER]